Uh,
oh,
chicken language video series introduced logic as a way of representing an
analyzing sentences,
but I skirted around questions of truth and establishing good arguments.
I'd like to take a stab at those topics,
those skills.
In this video,
we paid attention to the structure of sentences and use symbolic logic to
represent that structure.
On that front,
logic provides a handy way to sort out and clarify or statements.
Please make sure to go through those videos.
If you understand that material,
you can see that the logic of the statement,
like for example,
water is a liquid maybe represented as follows for all x.
If x is water,
then x is illiquid.
Now that you have that kind of grasp on logical statements,
you can extend your logic to whole arguments with multiple statements.
When I say argument,
I'm afraid you may be hearing heated exchange and forwards,
but I mean instead of series of statements made it supportive and assertion
together with the assertion drawn from those statements.
The supporting statements at our premises of the argument and the assertion that
follows from them is the conclusion right now.
I went to convince you that coffee is a food not in beverage.
Yeah,
you heard that right?
I'll start with some sentences.
We both except coffee is a beam.
Remember your logic here.
I'm saying that for all x,
if x is coffee than x and bean beans are food so it follows that all coffees of
food.
I brought you to a conclusion using two supporting premises,
but you might think I'm pulling something over on you here.
Maybe you can't even put your finger on it.
Hold your criticism for now and consider the structure of my argument first is
the form of my argument.
Any good?
Well what it is,
its form.
Let's abstract the argument to a is B,
B is c,
therefore a is c.
You'll find that however you fill in this structure,
the argument seems to work.
I bet you're even smart enough to see why you really are.
So let's move along.
If on the other hand I tried to fill out the argument with a structure like
premise one a is B premise to a is c conclusion,
therefore be as see,
it turns out that the argument doesn't work.
Apply this form to a few cases and you'll figure it out pretty quickly that it
fails.
Arguments with a working structure are valid arguments that are broken,
get the negative label invalid.
It would be premature of us to stop there and declare that we have a watertight
argument.
We've checked our structure,
but we haven't thought about whether we've filled our form with correct
statements.
The premises can be true or false and the conclusion true or false.
As a result,
I could propose that all soups are cold.
Anything that's cold can't bring your mouth so clearly soups can't burn your
mouth.
The argument has a valid structure but one of its supporting premises false
which impacts the conclusion I'm trying to draw.
If our argument is valid and has true premises,
it's a sound argument.
This may strike you as straight forward,
but it's easy to get lazy or manipulative with your logic and end up producing
or being convinced by unsound arguments.
Or should I say it's easy for the other guy but not forced?
The logical mind is yours.
Notice that either truth or validity can impact the soundness of an argument.
Unsound arguments include an invalid argument with true premises,
a valid argument with one or more untrue premises and an invalid argument with
untrue premises only.
A valid argument with true premises and sound,
a tidbit you may be aware of,
but our argument structure introduced above a is B.
B is c,
so a is c is called a syllogism,
so my coffee is food is a valid syllogism with,
I will assert true premises if that's all correct.
The argument is sound,
not all arguments are syllogisms.
Notice that we have two conditional premises.
If a then B,
if B,
then c and the conclusion follows from these conditions.
Therefore,
if a then c we could just use one conditional premise like if a then B,
if we assert in a second premise that a we conclude that you guessed it be,
I haven't looked outside these arguments to support them,
I just relied on the structure and persuasiveness of the premises to make my
point.
The meaning and words are all there for you to evaluate and if these are good,
then the conclusions good too.
That's deductive reasoning and the resulting argument is called a deductive
argument.
Once I start checking my facts outside my bare words,
things get trickier if I want to support my assertion that coffee is beans.
I have to use inductive reasoning to look at specific information in the real
world and make abstract generalizations about all coffee.
Even though I could never hope to check if what I'm saying is true,
even of a fraction of the world's coffee,
such claims are probabilistic and open until I can demonstrate that they are
false and arguments that take this line of reasoning are inductive.
For instance,
I can't demonstrate that my first premise is true of all coffee ever,
but I can state things that probably hold which requires inductive reasoning.
You might instinctively perform inductive reasoning by checking against your own
experience,
but there are even more methodical approaches
we called valid and true deductive arguments sound.
When we come across inductive arguments,
it's preferable to talk about cogency.
A cogent argument is valid and has probable premises.
I've thrown around the words true and truth.
If you're like most of us,
you intuitively feel you have some understanding of what those words mean.
The difference between deductive and inductive thinking may have raised a few
issues,
but let's tackle the issue of truth straight on.
Digest each one of the following questions and use them to get a broad view on
different perspectives of truth in logic and philosophy.
Is this statement true within the lines which is consistent with and doesn't
contradict other true statements?
Is this statement true when it corresponds to something in the real world,
Ken,
certain statements be asserted as true in and of themselves,
even self evidently truth than deductively follow from these assumptions.
Is this statement true when it proves to be useful or practical?
Is this statement true when enough people argue or belief that it is true?
It's truth.
Not An actual property of a statement at all,
but something else,
Ken true or the truth ever be predicated in a meaningful nonredundant way?
Hmm.
Whatever your intuition,
what do you make of my coffee is a food argument.
Do you think it sound in the next video,
I'll share a perspective on the logical fallacies and take another look at that
argument.